hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video for honor had its weekly dev
stream again so we're gonna recap for
you all like I normally do but before we
get into that I just want to say one
thing I did make a video yesterday it
took a lot of time and I thought it was
really cool that I would wanted to show
with you guys if you want to watch the
video being the I in the top right as
I'm speaking or it'll be at the end of
the video if you want to watch it after
this one I basically took for honor and
turned its settings all the way down low
and even into the files and it looked
absolutely disgusting
I put a lot of work into it I thought
you guys would enjoy that so if you do
want to check that out that'd be great
but continuing on with the actual video
I thought this was going to be the
stream that they showed off the warrior
trials in arena mode this was sadly not
the case they did show a few of the maps
and what they look like from the
overview but not actually in game that
might be next week on Thursday or we may
have just to do it ourselves they kind
of teased a little bit about how other
content creators will have videos on
this I don't know if that means early
access and some other people did or
they're just saying that they're going
to have videos out when that releases I
sadly didn't get really access to this
if this even existed for early access or
just so you know I will not be having a
video before this releases on the
training mode but once it does release I
will try to do a full in-depth video on
the arena mode and the training trials
if you're confused on what to do so
definitely be sure to check back on the
channel for that but first up they
showed some of the new maps that are in
the brawl duel and training mode game
modes and they're called pit sanctuary
and ring these are based off all skill
since there's no environmental hazards
and ledges and the only walls are along
the perimeter of the map these are also
going to be faction related so the ring
is in the knight faction the pit is in
the Viking faction and the sanctuary is
the samurai faction the fun fact just in
case you would like to know Dallben is
actually located in the ring arena send
in it since it is the knight faction so
just thought you'd like to know since
that's where he's been this whole time
like I said there was literally nothing
else based off of the info of that other
stuff I don't know if it's because they
have other youtubers doing videos or
they want us to make it when they when
the arena mode actually drops or they're
gonna be covering it I have no clue but
definitely check back next Thursday on
this one the small case that they do
happen to give us more details next up
blue is controller button mapping and
some console players have been wanting
this for a while me included for example
in the photo xbox guard break is
actually X but the devs change it to
right bumper which is originally the
light attack this will be available for
Xbox and ps4 I'm assuming on April 19th
when the full patch releases PC players
already have this so there's no need for
them to get this part of the update
since like I said you already have it
but that's really cool because a lot of
people have been one in the controller
button mapping for a while now next up
is balance changes and balance updates
in general and the back dodge distance
is going to be smaller allowing you to
not backed away when you're out of
stamina this is a real issue when you're
fighting an assassin character
especially especially on peacekeeper so
that was one of the reasons for this fix
the flecked got a style change before if
you deflected an attack and another one
hit you mid animation you would either
block here or just take the damage now
it deflects him behave similar to parry
where when you deflect the second attack
if you're mid animation you deflect
everyone now you're not doing damage to
everybody you're not deflecting and
stabbing deflecting and stabbing you're
just going to keep deflecting everybody
until someone finally stops hitting you
and then you do the damage to the last
person there's also going to be a mini
fix on reflex guard one instance that
was very important is our Musha with his
very fast light attack chain would
basically clap the cheeks of every
single assassin because of those light
attacks were super quick even though you
would think that you're blocking them
that should be fixed next patch I've
been waiting since the for this to come
out since the release of our motion and
I'm so glad that I'm not going to get
killed by him as much now in terms of
heroes apparently 14 heroes out of the
18 we have in the game got changes I'm
assuming most of these though are bug
fixes but the devs mentioned that they
will only be hitting the major key
points during the stream while the rest
will be coming next Wednesday I'm
assuming in that huge long patch note as
to make the stream not three hours long
and there wasn't really much in terms of
major key hits but I did manage to get a
few info for example on conquer his
light attack damage is now 13 instead of
15 Berserker slashing rush and his own
attack the slashing rush is the
backwards don't attack I believe now
does a total of 24 damage if you happen
to land all four hits instead of 30 to
go Keys demons embrace before if you
used two demons a bracelet opponent and
the teammate kills you or the teammate
kills the opponent that you demons
embrace you would still get the help
from it that's not the case anymore you
have to be the person to eliminate them
so that's sadly a little bit of a short
nerf to shougo key which really sucks
because that health is pretty necessary
and Centurion got a buff he has a health
buff of one
instead of 110 and now he has a light
heavy chain he used to have a light
light heavy chain but since a lot of
people would parry the second light it
made it almost useless that's why they
would always throw the random heavies
everywhere so now there's a light heavy
chain so your second light doesn't get
parried as much as I stated before there
is tons of other stuff on the other
characters and I will gladly be
recapping that if it happens to be in
the patch notes on Wednesday just they
didn't tell us anything and they're
probably going to be waiting for next
week but like I said I'll be gladly
recapping all of that for you next
Wednesday
continuing on the new content of the
week is elite outfits the elite outfits
aren't really that great for me at least
so if you want to pick those up that's
completely fine I'll show them on screen
while I talk about this and there's also
going to be a sale on battle outfits
until April 26 from today until April
26th 8 a.m. EDT one point five thousand
steel battle outfits are going to be
costing 1000 steel 3000 steel battle
outfits are now going to be 2k and 5k
steel outfits are now going to be 3k so
it's going to be a little bit of a
decrease on the battle off its if you
actually enjoy those and want to go grab
them it's up to you as I've stated
numerous times I'm not really big on
battle outfits but if you are that's
entirely up to you you can go grab these
since they are discounted next up is the
community order and it's gonna be called
tribute Vanquisher as a community when
as many tribute pvp and PVE AI matches
as you can the reward is going to be
2,000 steel like normal and you have to
participate in order to get the steel
that's gonna be a short simple one
probably get that done in a couple of
days so it's gonna be really nice to do
get some extra steel and then lastly to
end the video we have the may Road map
that you saw in the thumbnail and it's
structured similarly to the April to the
March and April one that we looked at
last time except obviously this is going
to be the end of April and the beginning
of May in the beginning you're gonna see
the training mode is gonna release on
April 19th with the training arena
apprentice trials training media and the
warrior trials so I'm gonna see if what
any of those four are and I'll gladly
like I said do an in-depth guide on
those when those release and dance of
death is going to be up which would
seems like for the entire week which is
really nice since they get to late last
week next up we have a new event
playlist with duel and this is only
going to be in the new arena maps that I
showed in the beginning of the video so
basically you it's only dual normal
1v1 accept only on those three maps
which is really nice that's going to be
going to the beginning of May so it's
basically end of April to the beginning
of May this is also going to be too type
of event community events type stuff and
that's going to be dueling executioner
and Warrior rush I don't remember if
these were repeats or not but those are
going to be coming out soon and an extra
mu fest should be releasing and May 4th
and the other stuff that is the lock
screen is just content of the week which
is really nice to see but other than
that guys it's going to be the end of
the video hope you guys did enjoy that
just to recap a little bit like I said
the road map there's gonna be the
training mode and the dance of death and
all the other content that's going to be
coming out throughout the end of April
and the beginning of May there should be
a full passionate release when the new
Patchett comes out on on Thursday the
actual updates going to be on Thursday
with the notes are going to be on their
website on Wednesday so I will gladly do
a recap of that and like I stated when
the training Charles comes out and all
that stuff I'm going to be doing an
in-depth guide on what it is how to do
it on that other good stuff so
definitely be on the lookout for those
videos in the future but like the video
if you guys did enjoy everybody does
help me out subscribe if you're new I
cover the leaks the news the
informational side of for honor I like
the cover such as new heroes leaks
patches all that good stuff my two most
recent videos are going to be on screen
if you guys do want to check that out
and with that guys hope you have a great
rest your day and peace up